WE HAVE AN IMPORTANT BACK
STORY ON HIM TONIGHT.
BUT, FIRST, DEMOCRATS RACE
AGAINST REALITY.
THAT'S A SUBJECT OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
ALL RIGHT.
THEY ARE CORNERED AND THEY
ARE OUT OF OPTIONS,
DEMOCRATS HAVE A NASTY, BUT
IT'S A REALLY PREDICTABLE
HABIT OF RACIALIZING
THEY DID IT TO BUSH.
THEY EVEN DID IT TO MCCAIN
AND, OF COURSE, THEY DID IT
TO ROMNEY.
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING IT TO
DONALD TRUMP SINCE THE DAY
HE ANNOUNCED HIS CANDIDACY.
>> FIRST WE HAVE TO DEAL
ON AND ON ABOUT MEXICANS AND
THEM BEING RACISTS AND
CRIMINAL.
IT WAS HORRIBLE.
>> GOD, EVEN IF THE NOTION
STRONG A WORD.
>> NO, IT'S NOT TOO STRONG A
WORD.
I ALSO THINK IT'S RACIST.
I THINK WE CAN USE THAT
WORD.
>> Laura: IT DIDN'T WORK
THEN AND IT WON'T WORK NOW.
BUT THEY ARE TRYING.
YESTERDAY SENATORS DURBIN
AND GRAHAM, THEY WANTED TO
FIST THEIR BIPARTISAN DACA
DEAL ON THE PRESIDENT.
AND BY THE WAY DICK AND
LINDSEY'S IMMIGRATION ACT IS
WE HAVE SEEN THIS BEFORE.
THEY PRANCED UP TO THE WHITE
MENTIONED WHEN IMMIGRATION
STALL WARTS CONGRESSMAN BOB
GOODLATTE FROM VIRGINIA AND
SENATOR TOM COTTON OF
ARKANSAS WERE ALREADY IN THE
ROOM AS WAS WHITE HOUSE
POLICY ADVISOR, IMMIGRATION
EXPERT STEVEN MILLER.
REMEMBER, JUST A FEW DAYS
EARLIER WHEN THE CAMERAS
DACA DEAL WITHOUT THE
FUNDING OF HIS WALL AND AN
END TO CHAIN MIGRATION AND
THAT STUPID VISA LOTTERY
SYSTEM YET SOMEHOW THE
FLATTERY ALONE CON TRUMP
THE PRESIDENT'S BASELINE AND
ACTUALLY, IF YOU CAN BELIEF
IT, THEIR IDEA INCREASED
CHAIN MIGRATION.
THE PRESIDENT, TO THEIR
ENRAGED AFTER BEING SPURNED,
SOMEBODY WENT TO THE PRESS.
THEY PEDALED THE STORY THAT
TRUMP HAD REFERRED TO HAITI
AND UNSPECIFIED AFRICAN
COUNTRIES AS S HOLES AND WE
SHOULD TRY TO GET NORWEGIAN
IMMIGRANTS HERE INSTEAD.
>> HIS COMMENTS SAID THINGS
WHICH WERE HATE FILLED, VILE
AND RACIST.
COMING THE NATIONS THEY COME
FROM [BLEEP].
EXACT WORD USED BY THE
PRESIDENT.
NOT JUST ONCE BUT
REPEATEDLY.
>> Laura: NOW THE PRESIDENT
IN A TWEET THIS MORNING
DENIED THAT HE USED THAT
PRESIDENT WAS REFERRING TO
AFRICAN COUNTRIES WHOSE
CITIZENS REGULARLY USE THE
VISA LOTTERY SYSTEM, NOT
HAITI ITSELF.
NOW, SETTING ASIDE THE
ALLEGED REMARK FOR A MOMENT,
WOULD YOU DESCRIBE ANY OF
THESE COUNTRIES AS CHANNING
I CAN'T
SHCAN'T
SHANGRALAIF THEY LIVED IN CLUB D
THEY WOULDN'T BE TRYING TO
CRASH OUR BORDERS.
IT'S IMPORTANT AFTER ALL THE
VERBIAGE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
SOME OF THE REAL FACTS ABOUT
A FEW OF THE COUNTRIES THAT
CAN'T KEEP THEIR OWN PEOPLE
FROM LEAVING.
NOW, LET'S BEGIN WITH EL
HAVE KNOWN VERY WELL FOR THE
LAST 30 YEARS.
SOMALIA, WELL, GUESS WHAT,
IT'S ONE OF THE LARGEST
STATE SPONSORS OF TERRORISM,
AND THEN, OF COURSE, SUDAN,
IT'S ONE OF THE FOUR
COUNTRIES ON THE U.S. STATE
SPONSORS OF TERROR LIST IN
ADDITION TO A LOT OF OTHER
BAD FACTS.
NOW, I WOULD NOT HAVE CALLED
RANK WITH CORRUPTION,
REPRESSION AND, OF COURSE,
IT'S OBVIOUS, ISN'T IT, THAT
THEY OFFER THEIR CITIZENS
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY ARE
HELL HOLES.
BUT, FOR THE DEMOCRATS AND
THEIR MEDIA ALLIES WHO ARE
FOREVER FAINING IN AFINT FOR
THE THIRD WORLD, FACTS DON'T
MATTER.
AFTER ALL, RACE BAITING THE
PRESIDENT IS SO MUCH MORE
FUN.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS A WHITE
WITH STEROIDS.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS RACIST.
>> WE VOTED FOR A RACIST.
THEY ARE NOT [BLEEP]
COUNTRIES.
FOR ONE DONALD TRUMP ISN'T
THEIR PRESIDENT.
THE KU KLUX KLAN, SOMEBODY
WHO COULD BE THE LEADER OF
THE NEO NAZIS.
>> WHEN IT CAME TO THE
ISSUES OF QUOTE CHAIN MY
IMRATION, I SAID TO THE
PRESIDENT DO YOU REALIZE HOW
MANY PEOPLE?
AFRICAN-AMERICANS BELIEVE
THAT THEY MIGRATED TO
AMERICA IN CHAINS.
>> Laura: NOW, OF ALL THE
THINGS I HAVE EVER HEARD
TRICKY DICK DURBIN SAY, THAT
ONE PERHAPS COULD TAKE THE
CAKE.
MIGRATION, WHICH HAS BEEN
PART OF THE VERNACULAR
SURROUNDING THE IMMIGRATION
DEBATE FOR DECADES
CONSTITUTES SOME TYPE OF
HIDDEN RACISM, A CODE
BOOING IN THE CROWD?
HE HAD TOO MANY MIMOSAS
EARLY IN THE MORNING.
ALL THOSE THINGS DEMONSTRATE
THAT DEMOCRAT DURBIN AND ALL
THE REST HAD NO INTENTION OF
WORKING WITH THE PRESIDENT
ON A DACA DEAL.
I DON'T THINK THEY DID.
IF THEY WERE TRULY CONCERNED
FOR DACA KIDS, DREAMERS
UPWARDS OF 30 YEARS OF AGE.
CALL THEM KIDS.
GIVE A LITTLE AND GET A
LITTLE.
THEY KNEW THE PRESIDENT
COULDN'T ACCEPT WHAT THEY
WERE OFFERING.
THEY HAD ZERO INTENTION OF
NEGOTIATING IN GOOD FAITH
BECAUSE SOMEHOW THEY THOUGHT
THEY COULD GUILT THE
BUT I GUESS THEY DON'T
REALLY KNOW HIM VERY WELL,
DO THEY?
THEY ARE OUT OF IDEAS AND
THEY HAVE NO SOLUTIONS.
THE RACE CARD IS THE ONLY
ONE THEY HAVE LEFT TO PLAY.
BUT, LOOK, DESPITE THE
AT WHAT TRUMP HAS ALREADY
DONE FOR BLACK AMERICA.
BLACK UNEMPLOYMENT IS AT ITS
LOWEST LEVEL SINCE THE
BUREAU OF LABOR STATISTICS
STARTED REPORTING THE DATA
BACK IN 1972.
IT'S AT 6.8%.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT IT WAS IN
16.8%.
BLACK FAMILY INCOME FELL BY
MORE THAN $900 PER FAMILY
JUST IN THE FIRST 8 MONTHS
OF THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION,
BLACK FAMILY INCOME HAS
RISEN BY MORE THAN $1,000.
I WILL TAKE THAT DIRECTION
ANY DAY OF THE WEEK.
WITH CHRYSLER NOW ANNOUNCING
PLANTS MOVING FROM MEXICO TO
THE UNITED STATES, THE STOCK
MARKET BOOMING AND WAGES
RISING ACROSS THE COUNTRY
DUE TO TRUMP'S TAX CUT
BACKS, AMERICA WILL THRIVE.
LISTEN TO GARY FROM TEXAS, A
CALLER ON MY RADIO SHOW THIS
MORNING WHO EXPRESSED, I
GUESS,
BEESS,
BESSS,
MANUFACTURED CONTROVERSY.
>> WERE YOU OFFENDED BY WHAT
YOU HEARD THE PRESIDENT SAY
AS AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN MAN?
>> NOT AT ALL.
HE IS TRYING TO FIGHT FOR
THIS COUNTRY AND GIVE BLACK
WE CAN'T DO IT IF WE KEEP
COUNTRIES, THAT DOESN'T MEAN
WE HAVE TO BRING THEM OVER
HERE AND TO COME FLEW OUR
CITY AND PUSH OUR PEOPLE
THE PEOPLE THE PRESIDENT IS
FIGHTING FOR, PEOPLE WHO
THEY ARE NOT ANTI-IMMIGRANT
BUT THEY WANT TO TAKE CARE
OF AMERICANS FIRST.
THE VETERAN SLEEPING ON THE
STREET TONIGHT.
THOSE WITH NO OPPORTUNITIES.
THOSE WHO WORK HARD BUT
SOMEHOW MAYBE ALONG THE WAY
GOT ADDICTED TO OPIOIDS,
THEY NEED HELP.
AND NO MATTER WHAT DURBIN OR
THAT THE SYSTEM IS UNFAIR
AND YOU BET THEY WANT IT
FIXED.
ONE THAT'S GOING TO SECURE
THE BORDER AND KEEP ILLEGALS
FROM COMPETING WITH OUR
HE IS FIGHTING ON BEHALF OF
ALL CITIZENS, THE PRESIDENT
IS FIGHTING FOR BLACKS,
WHITES, HISPANICS, ASIANS,
YOU ARE HERE LEGALLY, YOU